you need to think of food as that really
important thing
that fuels your body it allows us to be
more productive
it's how we can alter our health how we
can train harder how we can get
stronger how we can be better people
i've been meaning to reach out to you
for ages i'm
pretty crap at cooking i have like yeah
three
meals in my chef's repertoire
and you are my best friend that knows
how to cook food
either the the pete black belt brazilian
jiu jitsu in food making
and uh i just wanted to get you one
because i don't think it's just me
i think a lot of the especially the guys
yeah um
struggle especially people that want to
do fitness meal prep
they just don't have a very good range
of foods and i wanted to bring you into
your specialist subject making making
stuff taste good i wanted you to
take us through the principles and then
maybe give us some recipes as well
yeah absolutely i'm really looking
forward to it and um in terms of the
sort of
the meal prep and the fitness side i
used to compete as a runner
um 800 meters so for me that's where it
all really started with
making delicious food like because i'm
such a foodie and always have
been it's how do i how can i create
amazing food that fuels my needs as an
athlete but also
fuels my need to someone that's obsessed
with food so i've got quite
quite a good experience than this i love
it man so where do we start what's the
what's the principles we need to
understand
before we can even get into it yeah i
think for me
shopping and stocking your cupboard for
success is a great way to start because
i think in terms of let's start with
stock cupboard essentials like
so many things with a recipe you really
only ever need to buy the fresh stuff
if you've got an amazing selection of
like spices herbs
in the cupboard tins chopped tomatoes
beans your rice's pastas
and pulses and stuff and in the freezer
like frozen veggies
things like that you've always got a
meal to hand
but i could for instance open the
cupboard grab some pasta make a
delicious tomato sauce using tin
tomatoes some garlic flake through some
tuna
and put some frozen broccoli and i've
just made like an amazing meal
without even going to the shops so i
think the best place to start is
sort of stocking the cupboard for
success and i can certainly share
details on what i guess my
stock cupboard essentials are but yeah
olive oil
balsamic vinegar red wine vinegar
selection of herbs
selection of spices all dried um what
are the herbs and spices because people
always talk about that and then i just
look at the far corner of my kitchen
my housemates are pretty good foodie i
just look at the far corner and it's
just loads of words that i don't really
know what they are
yeah i mean there's so much choice but
for me if
if i had to have coarse spices cumin
ground coriander
chili powder turmeric garam masala
i think there's five solid ones you can
go down your zatars and razer hanuts and
stuff if you want to but i think with
those five you can do so much with them
and then for herbs probably like oregano
you can use it in so many italian things
if you're just making a tomato sauce
just chuck a bit of that and it's going
to taste better dried thyme
and probably some dried sage for your
sunday roasts and stuff like that
and i would say to be honest the oregano
is the secret one for me i use it in so
many different
things you're putting it on your cereal
in the morning putting on my cereal
putting them up put a cumin on my
porridge
um i've done that before instead of
cinnamon and it was half like by
accident
and you don't want to try it um and then
it like obviously pasta
rice and if anyone's interested in
adding more fiber to their diet just go
for the whole whole wheat a whole grain
alternatives
sort of slower release of energy and
then in the freezer
always got frozen peas always like a bit
of frozen broccoli and spinach
and they contain the same amount of
nutrition as fresh
and even like peas are actually fresher
sorry how do i describe that
yeah they are because they hold their
nutrition more because they're frozen
with an hour of picking
so if you go to the shops and buy a pack
of fresh peas
they've been in there five days you're
getting more nutrition out of a frozen
pea so
don't go thinking frozen fruits and
vegetables
aren't as nutritious because they are
and in some cases even even more so
with the frozen spinach do you get the
little pucks yeah
and in terms of value for money you know
what it's like
everyone's tried to wilt some spinach
and you put a bargain and you end up
with like a teaspoon worth of spinach
and it cost you about 253 quid for the
bag but in the
in the freezer you get way more weight
for your money so it's actually it's a
lot better value
and obviously it's not going to go out a
day in a hurry okay so that's what we've
got that kind of
stays in the cupboard and you need to
keep replenishing that what about like
i'm going into the shop
where where do i go where do you start i
think
where you need to start is before you go
to the shop make a shopping list
so many people get it wrong and they go
in without an idea of what they want so
for me
the whole shopping experience starts at
home generally for me i'll do a sunday
night and i think
where am i this week chances are at the
minute at home
but when things are normal it's like oh
maybe on monday
i'm at home but tuesday i've got an
event or something so
let's plan a meal that i can do for two
days that day and i've just got a quick
fix
eat the leftovers and reheat them and
then maybe wednesday again you might end
up doing another batch so i think
planning your food not around
necessarily what you find seating but
what's my week looking like which days
have i got time to cook which days
haven't i got time to coop
and that that just helps take the stress
out of cooking so
the answer to your question of where do
i start in the supermarket is
the top of the list of what it is you're
going to make that week and if you've
got a really well stocked cupboard of
the spices the herbs chopped tomatoes
and things generally you're only ever
going to need to go to the fresh aisle
for your proteins and potentially the
fresh veg because the rest you should
have in the cupboard
got you okay so what are we doing when
we're selecting meats
how do you what's your rule for
selecting meats okay i mean
depending on what your nutritional needs
are
i'm not i'm i'm not a nutritionist but
i have a bit of an understanding of it
obviously things like a chicken breast
is leaner than chicken thigh
um and for me i always like to buy
quality so we live in a world now where
it's easy to buy really cheap protein
like
chicken and things like that and my view
on it is i'd rather eat
less meat but of a higher quality say i
had a budget for
meat whatever 30 quid for the week i'd
rather eat
four days a week and go the others meet
free then eat seven days a week
on a lower quality so i i do try and get
the best quality i can afford
and what does that mean are you going to
a local butchers are you just happy
going into asda or whatever
m s and getting the more expensive range
yeah i'll go to m s and i know it's all
british in there and it's all really
responsibly sourced and farmed and for
me british i think is key like we need
to be supporting
british farmers not just with our meat
but also the veg and i think a massive
thing now is like carbon footprint
and so many people are going say
they're cutting out meat to have a
lesser impact on the environment
but if you all you're buying avocados
that have been flown in from the other
side of the world
and you're not eating seasonal british
food you might eat asparagus in december
but if that's been flown in from egypt
you might have been better off buying
some
chicken that was raised in the uk
because it's traveled less air miles so
i think
i'm eating with the season so when i go
into the shop i've got m
s i'm going to be thinking what's in
season we're coming up to asparagus make
sure it's british jersey raw potatoes i
think
we should be eating the best of british
all year
and that way you get the best taste you
get the sweetness strawberries in the
summer
and you get the nicest sort of um
how do i say it just eat british food
and you can't go wrong
and then i think educating yourself on
what's into season so for me
spring's coming up we've got asparagus
and like jersey royals like i say
so you can get really excited then in i
say excited i geek out over food
but then i i traveled the uk in 2019
and met different producers of all this
amazing food and i was in the isle of
wight eating these
tomatoes that had just come into season
and it was like eating sweets they were
so good so
if we can start to get some
understanding of what's in season i can
share all of this detail after after the
podcast
awesome man all right so we've gone to
the shops we've started to pick some
stuff up obviously we're gonna
you're gonna go through some recipes
towards the end and we'll work back and
people can make shopping lists from that
what what are some of the things that
people need to steer clear of that
aren't necessarily the obvious ones like
obviously don't absolutely hammer the
confectionery aisle but are there any
other things that people shouldn't be
putting in their trolleys that they
sometimes do
okay i mean that's a tricky one
everyone's sort of different and i
wouldn't want to say don't buy this
don't buy that it really comes down to
i think just just having some
self-control because it's the
confectionery aisle that kills
most people and i guess my my general
thing is if it's not in the house i
can't eat it so
it's if it's too tempting then maybe
just
try and steer past it but that's what
comes down to
if you've created a list and you go in
with the intention of having the list in
front of you i'm ticking off everything
on there i think it's going into shop
without
a plan it's like
you can't score without a goal if you
haven't got the goal in mind you're not
going to get it right so if you've got
the things on the list
get that and that then you're not gonna
obviously spend as much as well
because food costs money so if you stick
to what you want
we shouldn't be wasting any food there's
a massive
amount of awareness now around food
waste and the amount of things people i
can give you some details on how to
store food properly make it last longer
but people are throwing food in the bin
just imagine you're throwing money in
the bin
like how many times do you buy a pack of
peppers two of them will go a bit soft
and they end up in the bin or the best
one is rice you make a massive thing of
rice
because you're not so sure on how much
to make and it either goes in the bin
that night or you put it in the fridge
with good intent and then next lunch
time you're like
can't be asked for this straight in the
bin and the easiest way we can all
reduce our carbon footprint is to
actually stop throwing food in the bin
people don't realize the environmental
impact it has on on on the environment
going into landfills so
i guess a few tips on how to avoid food
waste things like herbs
you buy herbs for one recipe but it
might just be half a bunch you can make
herb ice cube trays so just chop up your
fresh herbs
in an ice cube tray fill them with water
put them in the freezer
then if you've made a curry a stew or a
soup you're literally just dropping
fresh herbs into them
um rice and things like that we're all
guilty of making too much
chill it as quickly as you can put it in
a window something let it cool
pop it in the fridge or the freezer if
it's in the fridge eat it the next day
and you just have to be confident to
reheat it but if you go to other
countries like china
like everyone knows egg fried rice that
is made with cold rice they cook it the
day before it has to be cold
to reheat it in the pan so it's just
thinking about how
other people cook around the world and
that for them is normal
to use a rice to reheat it whereas in
the uk i think people are scared of
terrified of it yeah
yeah massively i mean it can give you
food poisoning but if you just heat it
until it's piping hot and steam coming
off it generally if you put the knuckle
of your knuckle in and it's too hot to
touch it
it's sort of done and other things like
chilies you buy a pack of five
chillies put them in the freezer and you
can actually grate them onto things
um or you can drop them into a curry or
whatever so
we should be making the most of
everything we've got
this something i've thought about what
is the
minimum viable kitchen utensil
equipment pots pans knives things what
what do we need in this
for this setup brilliant answer i think
for all the recipes i do
i want to make it what my passion is to
simply inspire people to
cook from scratch and i think there are
so many barriers to cookery
how many times you've probably done it
you open a book and it says get out your
stand mixer
and then you need your mini food
processor and
a hand mixer or something like that and
you think well i haven't even got the
kit never mind the ingredients
so i always try and keep everything i do
so simple that
a chopping board and a knife a couple of
bacon trays and for me
a large non-stick oven proof frying pan
is amazing because you can do everything
in there from like a peripery chicken
you can start it on the hob
put it in the oven um so large non-stick
frying pan and then probably a small
saucepan
scrambled eggs and all of that and a
larger one to do your rice and things so
chopping board and a knife and i would
say invest in a good knife
if you've got a good knife it makes
chopping things easier the sharper the
knife the easier it is to cut through
what's a good knife what sort of price
range are we looking at
i use global knives and they that's a
brand
that i use and they are everything from
professional kitchens and you could pay
between 60 or 150 pounds for a knife
but if you can get just one or two good
knives like a a larger
it's called a chef's knife you can do so
much with it and if you actually look
after it
sharpen it take care of it it will last
for years and it'll make your job in the
kitchen so much easier
cool my uh my housemate toby
got a a pan
like you're talking about which is the
whole thing is is iron
and when he got it he was oiling it like
a cricket bat
yeah he was getting it and he's like
putting oil on it and stuff i'm pretty
sure he took it to bed with him at one
point
oh and right yeah no i know i haven't
used it uh
no but i i know that you can go really
sort of deep and
complex on those as well but you're
saying just that as your as your nice
simple makeup
for what you need yeah i think yeah so a
quick recap of that
large non-stick frying pan that can go
in the oven because you can do
everything in there from like soups
stews stir fries curries it's so so
versatile um
casseroles can do it because it can
finish in the oven a couple of bacon
trays
large saucepan small saucepan chocolate
board and a knife
and if you want to go to it i'd say a
mini food processor but everyone's got a
nutribullet now
so you can just make pestos in there
obviously smoothies
different sauces so that's actually a
really good bit of kit that
has everyone got it to make smoothies in
but it's really quite good
to do everything else as well no need
for a ceramic pot or a slow cooker
um do you know what if you're meal
prepping that could be a good idea i
don't generally use the slow cooker so
much
but if people want to do batch food
a slow cooker is a good investment it's
just having the space it depends how
much
room you've got because for me my thing
started as i moved to london
i was living in the smallest flat you
can imagine and i didn't have any room
for anything so my recipes just
naturally developed in the basic
equipment and simple easy to get hold of
ingredients
got you okay so what about freezing and
storing food effectively yeah
i think stuff anything you put in the
freezer first of all label it
because half the time you go and you
think when did i put that in there again
like
oh so we need some tupperware we also
need maybe some post-it notes
yeah i would say get some sticky notes
and for me i think freezer bags are
amazing because you can
put things in even if it was like say
curry you can put it in a freezer bag
flatten it down and you can actually
stack them up on top of each other
and you've it just makes you make the
most of your space
tupperware is great things like rice
so yeah some good freezer bags some
tupperware and i would say always label
everything
um and put the date on it that's the key
because stuff like rice you want enough
like a month and generally food i would
say use it was it within
three months but i think people are
guilty
of cooking loads of foods oh god's great
i'll pop it in the freezer and that
freezer just keeps filling up and up and
up and they're never getting anything
out
to defrost so for me i almost you have
intent thinking
make a note right i've got three
portions of chili which nights am i
actually going to eat them
don't just have it there for emergencies
like use the freezer plan
think on friday night on my meal plan
i'll be eating frozen chili that i made
last week and
make sure you're actually using the
stuff and when it comes to storing
things in the fridge
i always think look at how the
supermarket stocks the food
they're the experts if they've put the
peppers in the pack
keep them in the pack oh it was in the
fridge in the shop as well so i'll keep
it in the fridge here
so salad and stuff in the bottom site
tightly sealed the top if you want it to
last longer
obviously any protein and stuff and
chicken meat
on the bottom shelf reason you do that
is because
if you put it on the top if there's a
hole in the pack you don't want any of
the
juice dripping out and contaminating
everything else and also
use your senses as well because a lot of
things you can actually eat
a little bit longer than it might say on
the pack so don't necessarily
you've had a yoga open for one day
longer than it says like a greek yogurt
it's probably going to be okay does it
smell okay does it look okay
it probably is don't you what about
reheating food because okay there's
there's a few sort of obstacles to try
and navigate here
reheating food in plastics we've got
some a lot of concerns around bpa or
how it affects your endocrine system
that's before you get onto the taste
side of stuff and making something not
taste like ass again
see so for what you've mentioned there
for me i my first concern is
taste and the stuff you're talking about
i'm fully aware of it but i'd rather it
didn't taste like ass
because if you've gone to the effort of
making something delicious
even just a simple chili or something
for me i always think
reheat it i like to do it in a pan
if it's something like a batch cook but
it's it is easier in the microwave but i
would say decant it from the
the tupperware for the health reasons
but it does
generally taste like plastic doesn't it
when you heat it back up and then it's a
bit disappointing when you're eating
your dinner so
i think it's just making sure food's
piping hot
and that'll be steam coming off it and
when you're reheating things just keep
it stirring constantly if you're
reheating things in a pan
don't necessarily put it into a piping
hot pan to keep it and just heat it up
gradually
for me if i was reheating a portion of
curry or a chili
probably give it 10 minutes just let it
simmer let it come up to the boil and
then
it's it's going to be done but just
needs to be piping hot all the way
through
don't you so when we're working with
those freezer bags that you were talking
about before is it possible to get food
out of them without having to reheat
them in the bag
um yeah yeah definitely you can just
sort of like snip the top off and almost
knocked it out type thing yeah yeah
knock out but then if you're really
eating
food from the freezer i would say
defrost it overnight first
so if you've got we just use chili as a
good example
in a freezer bag pop it in the fridge
the night before you're going to eat it
and then it will be defrosted by the
time you come to get it out and reheat
it
so it'll be quicker and safer to reheat
um
so it will come straight out the bag
just pop it in the fridge overnight
a good option for the people who are
really
going to be anal about their endocrine
system and about concerns to do with the
plastics
um pyrex and a couple of other companies
have now started to make
glass tupperware that are still sealable
um and you can use those actually that's
something that i would say
uh that i would add to your minimalist
kitchen
toolkit yeah it would be like a glass
pyrex bowl
perhaps with a the plastic lid and it
just means you can put some peas and a
dollop of water in and throw it in for
four minutes
and you know that that's going to turn
them over the same goes for any
sort of mash that needs heating up stuff
like that yeah that's a great show
actually i think i didn't think of the
storage stuff to get hold of but
that is good and you know what they last
longer and it's it's
you could get a pyrex and it'll last you
i mean go i'd go home and
there's still pirates there that was
there when i was when you were a kid
yeah i think the impact on the
environment of just buying plastics uh
it's an investment it might cost a
couple of quid more but it will last
longer your food will taste better
and it just looks a bit nicer doesn't it
don't you okay so
meal planning in advance yeah what
what how are we doing now we're just
gonna sit down at the start of the week
and say right okay i need to cook on
these days i need to not cook on these
days
but i don't know how hungry i'm gonna be
or whether i fancy this on that day
how do you navigate that right how do i
navigate that i think
you don't necessarily have to do all
week at once
some people might they feel the pressure
oh i need seven days of food
just do three days at a time do what
works for you
um and i think that's where if you've
got an amazing stock covered
like we talked about at the start i
always do these things called like a two
day dish so everyone batch cooks a
bolognese
or something like that but then actually
i don't want to eat bolognese three
nights in a row
but what happens if i've got the
bolognese spaghetti bolognese on monday
then i've got this massive batch and i
go on tuesday right i know
i've got some cumin in the cupboard i've
got some chili in the freezer
and i've got some coriander ice cubes
i'm gonna chuck that
into a frying pan maybe throw an onion
and a pepper in that's in the back of
the fridge that needs using
put some spices in some dried oregano
drop in some coriander i've got the
chili in there
and you've turned last night's bolognese
into tonight's chili
and then maybe the next night you might
go i know i'll buy some
some tacos and i'll just fry that off
and put in some kidney beans
and make like a chili bean taco tostada
thing
maybe you can scoop some avocado on the
top so it's how do you turn one meal
into three meals for the next few days
is a great great way to do it but that
just comes down to having the right
stuff in the cupboard
don't you how long in advance
or what's the sort of maximum that you
think we can cook in one go is that
let's say it's a single guy or single
girl cooking for themselves
and they're maybe going to do sort of
lunch or dinner
for the next couple of days how much
would you try and do at once because
i have some friends that in the the
fitness industry who are trying to do
seven days like sunday
sunday evening is seven days of food
created in one go
you know what i i've never been one for
doing that and
i see things on instagram that said oh
meal prep sunday i'm thinking
you've actually just written a full day
of the week off by doing that because
they're literally they think this hey
it's just my opinion but
on a sunday i don't necessarily want to
spend five six hours
preparing seven meals if you can get
comfortable
with cooking regularly maybe you just
need to plan for monday and tuesday
and then spend half an hour on wednesday
so have
i think always just say have a think how
much time does it
is it going to take me to prep for seven
days it could be quite a lot of time for
me i would say three days is probably a
good amount
and then you wouldn't necessarily have
to freeze anything then you don't have
to go through the process of defrosting
so if it was a sunday you could
comfortably make dinner on sunday night
eat it on monday tuesday wednesday
and it's just thinking about how to
turn those leftovers into a new dish the
next day so
for instance i'm going to talk about
like a homemade zinger burger later
where you basically corn flake the
chicken
corn flakes flour egg not bread crumbs
corn flakes you get the crispiest
exterior delicious in a in a burger bun
with like a a low-fat yoghurt and uh
sweet chili sauce dip something like
that
then the next day if you've got that
chicken you could make a lovely salad
wrap
and just get like a wrap some fresh
salad shred that crispy chicken in and
put some more that yogurt sauce on the
top so it's
like you say keep it interesting and
think about
how you can turn it into something else
but you don't necessarily need to do
seven days in a row and also how fresh
is the food going to be by the seventh
day do you know what i mean
yeah that's i've never seen that done
before but to think about making a meal
that becomes the base for another meal
that becomes the base for another meal
i haven't thought about doing it like
that but it does make a lot of sense
i think it's a great one and i think it
really lends itself well to stuff that
we do batch cook which is generally
like slower cook things chili bolognese
curry because it's so easy to add
different spices
and stuff into there to totally
transform it into something else
got you uh before we get into the
recipes what are some of the most
common errors or any other errors that
you commonly see people making in the
kitchen or with meal prep or with
anything
else like what what do people need to
stop doing if you were to give a public
service announcement of like stop doing
this in the kitchen what would it be
stop overcooking fish because
you know what people are so scared
and i don't get hey don't i can't blame
them because the education
of how to cook in the uk isn't amazing
but
i get a lot of messages and feedback ah
i always overcook my fish
how do i stop doing it so just don't put
it in for so long like
you've got to think you can eat fish raw
you can eat sashimi you can eat sushi
so if you're buying fresh quality fish i
you can eat it slightly under done i
think people
are skip they overcook chicken and it
becomes dry
you can buy your meat probe if you
really want to
get anal to make sure it's cooked but as
soon as it's white and there's no pink
so don't overcook your proteins you
spend the most money probably on protein
enjoy it and also i think seasoning
people need to learn to season their
food properly because
lack of seasoning but also seasoning at
the right time so many people make
something and they're pouring loads of
salt on at the end
but actually seasoning at different
stages of the recipe in the cooking
process
completely changes the flavor so if you
season
say chicken half an hour before you cook
it that salt is actually going to change
the texture of the meat
also flavor the meat from the outside in
whereas if you're just pouring on at the
end
you're gonna get a different thing so
don't overcook your protein don't
well just basically learn to season your
food and also taste as you go
because everyone's palates are different
that's what i love about home cooking
you're not in a restaurant
you're in control you can make it how
you want so
if you like it a bit spicy you can add
more cherry if you like it more acidic
add more vinegar so
don't be scared to taste as you go
trying to think what else
people shouldn't do in the kitchen um
car it's a tricky one i think just
take your time like don't rush it
for me i want to make food and cooking
fun and enjoyable
and people rushing the process i've done
live cook alongs where i've got people
who've got their pan and
food and before i have on my hang on a
second like
like literally i did this charity cook
along and a
really nice group of six people there's
these two lads on the screen
and we're just doing this really simple
bacon pasta everyone else really engaged
what did we do next
i said if you got your pineapple he says
oh i've got the bacon and i'm like
see you're not even like just listen and
if you've got a recipe read it i think
literally mate and we had a crumble like
honestly the basics
we did this strawberry and almond
crumble it was delicious but
theirs wasn't because they made they
started the crumble mix before we
went and they ended up with like a
scondo
and that's just classic example of not
listening or reading so for me if i've
got a recipe in front of me
read it from start to finish and i guess
this isn't what people shouldn't do it's
just a tip to get you into a good habit
prep everything before you start cooking
so chop everything up get everything out
of the cupboard
and just have it all ready to cook and
then it makes the cooking bit a little
bit more enjoyable
yeah that is rich i mean dude i
i i'm so thoughtless with the way that i
actually
do stuff in the kitchen yeah incredibly
thoughtful when it comes to my
productivity systems yeah and how i sit
down at my desk on a morning and
organize my eisenhower matrix from
urgent to important and all this sort of
stuff
but the food which is literally fueling
my being
to be able to do everything else that i
decide in my life i'm like
uh right i'll see if i can listen to a
podcast
whilst i wash up whilst i do this thing
and maybe
answer an email oh i've got a bit of
time i'll ring someone while i'm like
just throwing
the same stuff that i always throw into
a pan and um yeah i
i get that respect respect the kitchen
but you know what i think that what
you've said is probably going to
resonate with so many people i think
you need to think of food as that really
important thing
that fuels your body it allows us to be
more productive
it's how we can alter our health um how
we can train harder how we can get
stronger
how we can be better people and give it
like you say give it that respect for me
do you know what it is
this is a great analogy with food and
cooking so many people think it's hard
it they can't do it i think everyone can
everyone's got the ability in them to
become an amazing home cook
and easiest way to describe it we all
start training in the gym
we're hitting it hard we've just started
though the first six weeks you are
aching you're seeing no gains
but the first time you look in the
mirror maybe it's i've gained some
muscle here
or i've lost some weight and then you
want to go back for more because it
starts to become addictive for me
and the feedback i get is the first time
you make a recipe from start to finish
if you're in total novice cooking you
taste it you go
or maybe your girlfriend your family
whoever go bloody hell that's delicious
and you put a smile on their face in
yours
that's the moment which is like when you
put the muscle on in the gym where you
go
do you know what that was pretty easy it
was really nice and it made people happy
i want to do that again and it becomes
like this habit but i think
exactly what you say treat it as
something it is important
and the more you do it and focus your
attention on it the easier it becomes
and the more fun you can have with it
and for me i like i put the radio on
like let's put the radio i'm a bit old
school like turn the dials and all of
that
um put the radio on get everything out
prepare it and just plan that time in as
you would plan in
your gym session you've planned it into
your day i imagine but a lot of people
just cram that food in at the end
as a means to an end very much a
utilitarian approach i think
people just see it as this is the thing
that sadly i have to do before i can put
the stuff in my mouth to fuel the things
that i want to do
and yeah don mcgregor the ex-co of
social chain
was on the show episode four and he said
to me you do know
that your brain and everything that your
body is made of
is built by the stuff that you put in
your mouth that's it yeah
and you don't realize the the connection
is
the cells in your body the quality of
the cells in your body is directly
influenced
by the food that you choose to eat and
there's like dude when i
when i think back to to uni and this
maybe have been before
your uh food awakening as well
i i [ __ ] you know there will have been
weeks that i would have gone without a
vegetable like
like weeks and weeks it's just madness
isn't it and
ah it really is and you know what i
always say food is a joy
and we are lucky enough to live in the
the society that we're in to have access
to amazing quality ingredients
nutritional advice um it's all there in
front of us and
on it like there are people out there
who don't have access to any food
whatsoever
so i feel that we should respect it even
more because we do
have the ability to go and buy something
really really good
we've got the ability to you could go on
the internet now and
find the health benefits of salmon how
to cook it in a million different
sources
instant access to how to even cook the
food
that you can you've got access to so i
think you've got to treat it with
respect and
one thing especially i think we've found
in lockdown
the one thing we can control in the days
what we for dinner
that's what i'm getting in my world of
food and it's something that i think in
lockdown people have started to do more
and realized that is the one time in the
day they can actually get together with
a family and enjoy it as a social thing
so i think there's so much more to food
that we need to think about than just
fuel yeah i mean seeing it as a
as the experience of making the food as
a potential source of pleasure
or even the eating of the food not just
that it's tasty but
in the same way as when you clean the
house before your missus gets home
because you know it's going to put you
in the
in like her good books the the same
thing can be done
you can give pleasure and receive
pleasure just through the act of making
a nice meal again
something else that i have never never
dipped into
and do you know what really i think got
me into food
as a kid i'd get in from school and i
just have this obsession of
how you can turn some raw ingredients
into a meal and
my parents work really hard and they
work long hours and i would just get in
from school and every night from about
nine eight nine years old i'd make
dinner for my mum and dad
and just to see the joy of putting the
food down on the table
that i'd made and they're eating it and
they're smiling we're all sat together
and i thought you know what
it's not even about what's on the plate
out here together
talking and having a good time and i
think
there's just so much more to food than
the fuel however
i would say when you're an athlete
because i know there'd be a lot of guys
and girls listen to this that train hard
the volumes of food you've got to eat it
can become boring but that's why you've
got to make it taste good
um so interestingly enough there was a
good documentary on amazon about the
the tour de france and some of the teams
and how the nutrition has changed
and now they have like michelin star
chefs that follow them on the tour with
a food van
and they literally go off foraging
sourcing ingredients from local farms
dairies cheese
because these cyclists just haven't eat
about eight nine thousand calories a day
and they're like you really think i'm
going to eat 9 000 calories of boiled
chicken and rice
with no seasoning or flavor so they're
paying these michelin star chefs to
follow them and
uh that's the key i think for anyone
training keep it tasty
and then you'll be able to eat as much
food as you need to
to fuel yourself um yeah and i suppose
on the converse of that as well
if you were needing to put yourself into
a calorie deficit
that you can you can make food which is
slightly cal
more calorie sparse more tasty and more
appetizing
you know everyone's kind of turned their
nose up
a plate of cauliflower and broccoli and
spinach a little bit but i imagine if it
was done by
chris baber it might taste a bit
different well i think that that's
that's the thing to think about veg
because you mentioned when you're at uni
you weren't eating much of it
vegetables are lowering carbs um
but if you think about your stomach it's
only one size it doesn't know if it's
it's full so things like the cauliflower
is great for filling you up but how do
you make it
tasty and broccoli well for me with
broccoli tiny splash of oil in the pan
some garlic
throw the broccoli in you can put a bit
of chili in there splash of soy sauce
even a tiny drizzle of honey
and you've made like this sticky sweet
salty sort of caramelized broccoli which
could have just been boiled and boring
so it's how do you make this stuff more
adventurous and it just comes back to
herbs and spices and
stuff you stuff you've got in the in the
stock cupboard chris
cool what's the first recipe we're gonna
learn okay so the first
recipe is a really easy chicken booner
because i think
i mean hey i love an indian takeaway i
love it
my first job was in a michelin star
indian restaurant in london i've got
such a passion for indian food
and everyone has this association of
indian food unhealthy it's from the
indian
you can make some delicious curry so
chicken booner this is a great one for
batch cooking
really simple really basic stock covered
ingredients as well
you can do it with chicken thighs or
breasts if you're doing chicken thighs
and anyone wanting to watch the calories
top tip for meat trim off any visible
fat and you're literally trimming off
calories as you go so any white [ __ ]
you snip it off but
literally cook your onions about 10
minutes in olive oil
until they're really nice and golden and
that's going to add sweetness and depth
of flavor
some garlic some ginger and some chili
goes in in with the chicken
and then all you need is turmeric and a
good curry powder
sprinkle that and coat the chicken loads
of tinned tomatoes a good handful of
peppers
and literally just simmer that for 20
minutes
until the chicken's cooked and the water
sort of evaporated from
from the pan and then finish off with
lemon juice and coriander that's really
healthy it's low in fat high in protein
and you can obviously serve that with
any rice that you want to
to serve it with top tip for basmati
rice to get it perfectly fluffy
you always go for the absorption method
which is say one part rice
to two parts water so if you've got a
mug full mug
of rice rinse it under a tap in a sieve
until the water runs clear that takes
off the excess starch
pour the rice into the pan with two mugs
of water so
one part rice two part water lid on
lowest heat ten minutes perfect every
time so
that's a chicken bunner simple easy to
get hold of ingredients
have it for your dinner that night then
you can definitely put that in the
fridge or the freezer
and if you didn't fancy curry the next
night why don't you do like a
a spicy chicken wrap you could toast up
a little uh tortilla
you could shred in some salad some uh
some cucumber some tomatoes
mix some uh greek yogurt with mint sauce
just out the fridge
put it in and you've just made like a
spicy tikka wrap for lunch the next day
we should say the on your instagram
which is
at chris baber yeah at chris baber um
there'll be a breakdown of all of the
different recipes that we're going
through today so
for everyone that's listening you don't
need to write this down frantically or
like
keep on rewinding or whatever um but you
can have you can look at look at your
instagram while you're narrating
and they're rushing around the kitchen
trying to get this all done okay so
we've got a chicken bun and what's next
um well we talked about this uh sort of
zinger burger fake away i think the fake
ways are great
because it's the food we crave and love
isn't it but you can make it healthy so
basically we're gonna take a lovely lean
chicken breast
dip it in some flour dip it in some egg
dip it in
crushed up corn flakes is the secret
ingredient here
and then show you let's go back a step
in the flour put some smoked paprika you
can put some cumin any spices you've got
you could even use fajita mix whatever
you've got in the cupboard you can put
it in there
then into the bread cru into the corn
flakes and literally bake it in the oven
no deep frying or anything
like that so just on a baking tray
on a baking tray 200 degrees it'll
probably take about
25 to 30 minutes depending on the
thickness but because you've got that
um egg and conflict coating it keeps all
the juiciness in the chicken
then literally toast up you could do a
brioche bun you could do a whole wheat
bun whatever you want
um or you could go boneless if you want
to drop the carbs
and then for like a healthy little sauce
some greek yogurt
you can just add a squeeze of honey
squeeze a lemon and
a little bit of mustard or sweet chili
sauce and just spread that in and you've
just made a delicious
um spin on a on a zinger burger
really crispy and we talked about this
one earlier
just slice that chicken up the next day
and you can again put that through
salads
or you could even reheat that and put it
into like a rice dish
but you're just going to have this
crispy crumbed chicken
which is pretty basic and it could lend
itself to whatever way you want to go
with it
how would you add uh some extra filler
in that like a like a wedges or
a veg how could you do some can you
propose some veg
and some wedges or something that can go
in the oven along with that so it's just
like in and done
a hundred percent so for me sweet potato
wedges um
love them just cut cut a sweet potato
into sort of one centimetre thick wedges
tiny drizzle of olive oil bitter
seasoning you can put any spices on you
want
put them in the oven you keep the skin
on or are you uh have you peeled it
i keep the skin on because there's a lot
of nutrition in the skin
in terms of veg to go with it you could
make a really simple coleslaw
people might think coleslaw is difficult
or whatever but literally just shred up
some cabbage really really fine
that's where a sharp knife comes in
handy maybe grate some carrot
a little bit of red onion some greek
yogurt squeeze of lemon juice
salt pepper and that is a delicious
coleslaw
perfect i love it man okay so we've got
chicken burger we've got chicken bunner
what's next yeah um
we want to do this peri-peri chicken so
everyone loves
perry perry chicken and for me we talk
about as well value so
buying a whole chicken is far more
economical than
buying just the breasts or the thighs
and you can spatchcock a chicken
which some might sound complicated but
literally you flip the chicken over
and just use a pair of scissors and you
cut the backbone out and then you can
just flatten the chicken out
and then you make a marinade just with
red wine vinegar some olive oil
some paprika and oregano and some chili
whiz it up
cover the chicken in it pop it in the
oven for 45 minutes or so until it's
cooked all the way through
spatchcock in the chicken speeds up the
cooking time so much
and you're going to get this like crispy
perry perry chicken skin
and that one would be perfect with a
sweet potato wedges but for me i love to
do like a spin on the matcha
peas that you get in nando's
classic frozen peas take them out uh
you can use mint sauce from a jar or
just a bit of fresh mint or you can even
use the mint ice cube thing that we
talked about
salt pepper a little bit of chili if
you've got some creme fraiche or yogurt
you can put a bit of that in to make it
a bit creamy
and just give it a good mashup peri-peri
chicken and
matcha peas and you could do your roast
veg or whatever in there or
be good with rice but then that one
really is perfect to
think that i might just have a quarter
of that chicken that'll last another
three days in the fridge and you can
literally use that for whatever you want
so
it's a pretty basic thing you could do a
nice stir fried rice chicken fried rice
with it the next day maybe you've got
some leftover rice
or you could just put it through a salad
or in a sandwich but
the key thing is there you've roasted
the chicken and it's gonna last three
days
you can go whichever way you want how do
you take the backbone out of the chicken
um so if you visualize the chicken flip
it onto a board breast side down and
then
right all the way from neck to arse
there will be a bone which is about half
an inch thick
and literally sharp pair of kitchen
scissors you can snip all the way up one
side
all the way up the other and just
literally peel it out
and that's it and then what you would do
is take the chicken
flip it back over and then with the heel
of your hand you just press it down and
you'll hear a crack
and it'll just flatten out a bit like
when you're at the masseuse and they
press your back down
that same action and you'll hear the
same crack and then that's your chicken
spatchcock and that's a tip if you want
to speed up
the cooking time of the chicken from
maybe an hour and a half to less than an
hour
awesome what about
vegans who are listening who also need
to train who also want to get their
protein in what's
uh your favorite high protein
vegan meal vegan for me you know like i
think
i worked in a fine dining indian
restaurant and in india
because of religious reasons a lot of um
people don't eat meat
or dairy products as well in some
instances and there's some amazing vegan
curries
where they just happen to have been
vegan for however many hundred years but
it's never been labeled as that so
things like a delicious chickpea curry
um
i recently did a really nice not on a
curry vibe but for
more of an asian spin like a teriyaki
tofu if you get like a
firm tofu block and just literally make
soy sauce with some honey
squeeze of lime juice um you can put
some grated ginger and garlic
marinate the tofu for maybe half an hour
or even overnight
and bake it in the fridge and you get
this sort of caramelized
sweet sticky savory block of tofu
that is just perfect on top of some i
don't know you could just use rice
noodles
put some veg through it or even another
veggie
vegan option you could do like a vegan
satay
um veggie noodle stir-fry kind of like a
chow mein
and you could just get loads of peanut
butter for you for your protein
mix it with some coconut milk a bit of
soy sauce some sweet chili sauce some
garlic and ginger
quick saturday sauce stir-fry some rice
noodles thrown loads of veggies
toss it all through and then you can
even put the tofu through that on the
top
and there's so many options but i think
for me pulses and beans are probably the
thing
what's the first thing um like pulses
like lentils
things like that they're high in protein
they're packed full of fiber
and they're a great replacement so if
you're doing chili or bolognese you can
do that with lentils um
i think it's really underutilized it's
really good value for money and it comes
in a tin and
all you have to do is add it to things
so i had my um
blood work done by a company called
inside tracker in america a couple of
years ago
they're out of boston and um they looked
very closely at my blood profile and um
from that derived some foods that i
should add into my diet that would
positively impact different different
profiles so
um how is your insulin levels looking
how is
the different growth factors looking and
um one of the
things that needed impacting was my
lipid profile and they said that
the single most i had like the total
cliche
young guy um issue and the
the best thing that they suggested was
beans
different types of kidney beans and
other tin beans
and they just said just add that in a
couple of times a week
and it fixes downstream the downstream
um blood profile effect it fixes
most of the things that most people have
as a problem
they're eating so widely around the
world i don't know that we as much of
them in
in this country as as elsewhere but they
are it's like a soup well
am i allowed to say it's like a
superfood they're so good for you
it's the protein the fiber but there's
so much nutrition and people don't
realize like
a tin of beans is one of your five a day
i think about three tablespoons of like
chickpeas kidney beans what cannellini
beans
people don't realize that and this
they're a good source of carbohydrate
as well so i'll be honest most days for
lunch i'll incorporate
some beans into a salad or i'll even add
them into recipes because i know how
good they are for you but an amazing
source of protein that's for sure
what's next um oh i was thinking about
like a drunken noodles which is a thai
dish
and this is a good one if you are on
a time frame so if you've got 10 minutes
and you want to make something really
delicious
literally prawn drunken noodles is rice
noodles you just soak them in boiling
water
you need your prawns you need some eggs
and you need some cherry tomatoes and
you can
add any veggies you want in this pak
choy and then
for the sauce it's literally oyster
sauce some soy sauce
some fish sauce and some sugar stir that
together
then you literally fry off some you can
put some shallots or something if you
want
add the prawns in add the tomatoes in
add the egg scramble the egg a little
bit
any greens pour in the sauce
add the noodles stir fry it together and
in less than 10 minutes you've made like
a thai street food dish
which is proteins carbs and delicious
and you can get some veg in there as
well
how hot the pan for that oh really
really hot for that so anything like
stir fries and things you want it super
super hot
that's why it's always key with thing
like a stir fry to get everything
prepped because you're not going to have
time to start chopping something when
the prawns are and it's all going to be
sort of overcooked
so super hot smoking hot if you put some
oil in you should see like a shimmer
just coming off the pan
but you can do that it doesn't have to
be prawns you could use beef you could
use chicken
things like that just lend themselves
well to any any kind of protein
and you reckon that's under 20 minutes
from start of prep until
food is made yeah i've done that on
instagram live i think we were done in
about 18 minutes or something like that
it's um yeah super easy and again you
can just adapt it you don't need to
stick to the same recipe every time try
with actually try with green beans
broccoli whatever you want and we should
be eating a variety of different
fruits and vegetables so it's a good
sort of recipe to experiment with new
things
there's a lot of protein in that one
when you've got the eggs in when you've
got the meat and when you've got the
noodles in
yeah there's tons of protein i think
that's the other thing like egg noodles
people don't realize are a really good
source of protein so
a nest of egg noodles has become uh i
think they're about 40 grams i think
there's about seven grams of protein in
there
so if you have a couple of nests of egg
noodles
for your portion there's like another 15
grams of protein out in no way
yeah out of nowhere i think there's a
lot of hidden protein in food as well as
like beans noodles people don't even
realize even pasta you know i think 100
grams of pasta's got about seven eight
grams of protein in it so
it's everywhere what's the uh what's the
rules for
egg noodles because sometimes i see them
fresh sometimes i see
i think you can get them frozen as well
have you got any rules for that um
i wouldn't say it's a rule just check
check the packet instruction for me with
egg noodles i always just buy the dried
ones
um and then you would just cook them in
boiling water for about four minutes and
then you can add them into
to to a stir fry or a sauce
but then they're really good to be
chilled as well and kept in the fridge
and
you can make a delicious salad with it
if you just cook some noodles shred some
veg
squeeze a lemon bit of soy sauce and
honey nice zingy sort of noodle salad
but then other types of noodles you can
get rice noodles so if anyone's sort of
not eating dairy
rice noodles are it's a noodle made of
rice they
they mix the rice with water grind it to
a paste and then
form it into noodles and it's dried and
all you have to do is pour boiling water
on it to sort of bring them back to life
and you can eat them
then and there or you can add them into
sort of stir fries then you've got like
the straight to wok noodles
that you've probably seen in a packet
that are kind of soft and they're in a
sealed packet and again that just
literally as it says
straight into the wok so just read the
packaging as well i think a lot of times
people buy products and
they bypass the thought of oh i don't
need to read that and then they wonder
why it hasn't worked it doesn't taste so
good but there's generally instructions
on
on everything we buy now yeah what's
next
um well i was gonna i sort of went down
the teriyaki tofu route
but i was gonna do like a teriyaki
salmon because i think this is another
quick one which
people can do in less than 10 minutes
really get some salmon
put some soy sauce some grated ginger
some garlic
a squeeze of honey if you've got any
mirin
if you've got that in the cupboard you
can add it if not squeeze a
squeeze of lime juice and then literally
just soak the salmon in it
pop it in the frying pan cook fry the
salmon off for probably a couple of
minutes on each side
pour the rest of the sauce in and
because it's got the honey it's going to
reduce down and go really sticky and
sort of glaze the salmon
and i love to do stir fried broccoli and
garlic with that which is just
a little bit of sesame oil in with the
broccoli loads of garlic and chili
uh toss it all together and then if you
want to add carbs bit of rice on the
side and that i mean
i think gone are the days of like you're
saying the chicken and broccoli brigade
of
boiled chicken uh and broccoli and plain
rice
you can do so much more i mean
essentially that would be chicken
broccoli
salmon broccoli and rice but by making
the simple teriyaki sauce and a bit of
sesame oil on there
on the broccoli you totally transform it
right what else what else have we got
um i'm trying to think is there anything
you you'd want to know i want to know
about steak i want to be able to do a
good
sort of steak of some kind perfect so
chimichurri steak is something i love to
do i do it quite often so chimichurri
sauce is sort of
an argentinian sauce and it is made with
fresh herbs like parsley and coriander
and you use red wine vinegar
olive oil the chopped herbs and a bit of
oregano salt and pepper and it's
delicious and it's really
zingy and fresh because i think if you
go to a restaurant
when when they open again we do
hopefully pretty soon
a lot of times steaks have like quite a
creamy and rich sauce
but this is actually really fresh and
vibrant and for me
i would normally go it depends how lean
you want to go so for anyone listening
philip's steak is the leanest pretty
much
no fat in that whatsoever then you've
got like rumps and sirloins and then a
ribeye they're pretty accessible steaks
ribeye probably the fattiest
of them all what steak do you like chris
what would you order in a restaurant
uh i would tend to order whatever the
person sat next to me says i should
order
that's okay i'm one of those were you
okay what are you
getting yeah what are you having it
looks good looks looks good that how are
you having
medium yeah medium yeah i love medium uh
i don't really know man i mean what
how would you break down the different
tastes of steak can you give us a
a brief sort of steak steak class
yeah i mean it's something like a fillet
steak there's very little
this is the best way to think about
steaks fat is flavor that ra fat is a
carrier of flavor
that is why things like beef dripping
tastes so good
goose fat fat is just ram for there's
more flavor and fat than flesh
so if you've got a fatty cut of steak
like a rib eye
it's gonna taste more beefy than
a fillet steak which doesn't have as
much in it so
things like a fatty ribeye steak
that's where something like a
chimichurri sauce you need that acidity
to cut through the
the fattiness that you're going to get
in your mouth whereas like a fillet
steak because there isn't any fat that's
why like a nice creamy sauce like a
mushroom sauce or a peppercorn goes well
with it but i think the easiest way to
look at it is like
philip being the leanest rump steak
probably one down
and then sirloin and then ribeye rib eye
definitely packs the most flavor but
then again it's the fattiest
one one of them all but i would say
for me rump steak or rib eye steak with
a chimichurri sauce
season the steak on each side drizzle
the steak with oil
not the pan it stops it all splashing
around and you always
want your steak to be at room
temperature and that goes with anything
you cook and protein wise because
if you take a steak out of the fridge if
you think about it
the ins that that steak is going to be
about three degrees all the way through
so if you put that steak in a if it's
quite a thick steak or whatever and you
pop it in a really hot griddle pan or
frying pan whatever
the outside of the steak is going to be
caramelized but the inside of the steak
is going to take
longer to come up to that temperature so
it's basically going to be blue and raw
in that like properly raw in the middle
but
really caramelized on the outside
whereas if that steaks at room
temperature
the inside of the steak is already about
18 degrees
so you get an even cook on it the
outside
by the time the outside's caramelized
the inside will be nice and
sort of medium rare and again with like
chicken and stuff
if you're frying a piece of chicken and
it's freezing cold out there i'm not
freezing but like really cold out the
fridge by the time the inside
the heat penetrates to the middle the
outside is going to be burnt
so always have your steak in your meat
at room temperature when you cook it
so season the steak salt and pepper
really hot pan
in the pan don't i never mess with it
once it's in i only ever turn it once
a normal sort of thickness of the steak
probably a couple of minutes
flip it over and just make sure it's
nice and caramelized on the bottom
and by say caramelize i mean like that
sort of golden crispiness
that's something called the meal odd
reaction and it's the sugars
caramelizing flip it over another couple
of minutes
and then if you want to be really
indulgent when it's just about done you
can add butter into the pan
and baste the steak in butter and it
will just soak up
those buttery goodness flavors and but
to be honest if you're doing chimichurri
sauce i don't tend to put the butter in
but the chimichurri just simply finely
chopped
coriander and parsley some oregano red
wine vinegar drizzle of olive oil
and that for me is just a perfect steak
steak supper what would you serve that
with
um you could do for me i would think
what what time of year am i eating if it
was the summer or
sorry spring coming up i'd probably do
some asparagus i'd go for
think about what's in season i love
broccoli with it or like a lovely rocket
salad
something like that sweet potato wedges
again a bit of a healthier option
um but one of my favorite ways with the
chimichurri steak is the ciabatta
bread and just make like the ultimate
steak sandwich and
all of the flavor just drips into the
ciabatta and you've got that sort of
herby spicy sauce
unbelievable and the top tip here anyone
making a steak
always cut it against the grain when you
cut it because
if you think about the grain of a meat
i'm trying to think of the best way to
put this across
if you want ultimate tenderness cutting
against the grain means you're going to
bite down on
short fibers so they're just going to
sort of collapse in your mouth
whereas if you go with the long way
you're going to have these big long
stringy fibers that you're essentially
chewing on yeah of course
yeah that makes so much sense because if
you think about like
some spaghetti hanging upside down as
the fibers if you cut the long way with
the spaghetti you've got them long
strands in your mouth and it's chewy but
if you cut against them
then the fibers are like the loads of
little bits of spaghetti that way
and they just break straight down so
that can you could cook the steak
perfectly but if you don't cut it
against the grain
you could still be chewing on it make
the best steak in the world but knack it
with your knife and fork once you sit
down at the table yeah literally so
always cut the steak against the grain
dude i love that that's that's my i
think that might be my favorite
hack to come out of today uh any of the
bits any other
sort of final thoughts or things that
you
think people need to know i think
people just need to for anyone that's a
bit of a novice in the kitchen
anyone can cook delicious food i think
everyone's got the ability to do it
you've just got to give it a go and have
some confidence to do it i mean in
lockdown i've done all these
live cook alongs with families and
children and i'm getting messages from
parents and kids who've
never cooked before these recipes that
we're talking about easy enough for
children to cook
so i think they're easy enough for
everyone to cook in the end of the day
it's just food don't be scared by it
if it doesn't quite work out you can try
again next time but
i guess the other one is if anyone's got
any questions
or they want to know more they can
message me and i'll get back to everyone
that has
any questions on food or whatever where
should they go
uh just straight to my instagram if if
anyone i mean there's recipes all over
the place on there but if anyone had
anything more specific
you can just send me a message but it's
just at chris baber which is b-a-b-e-r
if you can't no one knows my surname it
depends where i go in the country it's
either baba barber
baber um but yeah just jump onto my
instagram
is there's food everywhere on there
recipes advice
all the stuff we covered dude i wonder
how many people are going to have a more
tasty week coming up because we've had
this conversation
tonight oh man i hope so and i i had one
question
for you actually well two hit me number
one
last meal what would it be allowed three
courses oh
god okay so as a starter
i'm a big fan of a sort of a pill pill
prawn
type thing um like garlic maybe on it
maybe it's sort of ciabatta on the side
that would be quite nice um
as a main as a main i would i'd be
tempted to go for steak
um i i i do tend to enjoy it with
mashed potato like some nice sort of
um like a classic sort of british sundae
basically a sunday a sunday
uh lunch and then man it's it's got to
be a crumble
to finish yeah for me i'm all over a
crumble
hot crumble cold custard
i love that contrast so good yeah
so good and the other question what's
your favorite sandwich
oh man so my my son
johnny uh one of the guys that's
regularly on the show he has a heuristic
around
buying sandwiches for protein and he
says that you should look to try and get
a good sandwich has 10 to 15 percent of
the calories from protein
he says that's that's a realistic uh
ratio to find
so i've used that heuristic a few times
if i was in a
in boots or whatever i just tend to
gravitate towards the chicken salad
sandwich that's a fairly basic one
but i've had some really good uh like
club sandwiches
so like the you know the triple triple
bread
the crusts are already gone off the
bread the little um
triangle someone skewed it with a a
stick and you've got some yeah yeah and
it's you need to eat it in like three
different goes
but that's i think that's my what about
yours what would yours be
the the sandwich one's hard i i i
gravitate between
leftover christmas dinner sandwich
like the turkey the stuffing pigs and
blankets or
hot beef and gravy in a soft white bun
with some maybe some caramelized onions
or something like that as well
yes now we're talking maybe a bit of
mustard and just i want the gravy
dripping everywhere but
i i could literally talk well i said i
could talk about food all day i do it's
my job i love it
um but you know what i love the way that
food brings people together
we came on here just to talk about food
and we've managed it for like an hour
and a half and
it it feels like we're only just getting
started with it but it's it's a
like you say it's an it's something that
we need to do we do
do but i think people are it's so much
of a habit and a routine that people
don't take a step back to look at what
else food does mean to us as
people and how important it is and the
benefits it can give us as well
weirdly the things that have the biggest
impact on
our lives are the ones that are so close
they're staring us in the face and we
don't look at it
so few people have a sleep routine so
few people that i know actually
understand
i need to go to bed at the same time i
need to wake up at the same time i need
to have dark blinds ideally blackout
blinds two sets of curtains
my bedroom needs to be colder than i
think it needs to be and i should have
a shower before i go to bed they don't
understand that maybe some magnesium
supplements would help or some cbd
supplements would help
that not having food just before you're
about to go to bed is good
all of this stuff so and that's just
sleep and then when you think right okay
i understand i need to understand about
hydration i need to understand about how
i spend my mornings how i wake up
my caffeine consumption before i get out
of bed on the morning people
having the coffee machine ready for them
to wake up so that they can wake up and
have a coffee
when their adenosine system isn't active
for 90 minutes
what you want is salt lemon water
ice cold glass get your adrenal system
moving that's what's active for the
first 90 minutes
and then if you choose to have a coffee
after 90 minutes or
two hours or so that's when your
adenosine system comes online
and you'll get so basically the first
coffee you have in the morning easiest
hack for anyone that wants to reduce
their caffeine intake
and you can't let go of the the balloon
tether
that is your first coffee just make it a
decaf
make it a good a good quality decaf and
then you're going to not you're going to
fulfill the i need a coffee to wake up
sensation because it's a habit
but you're not you're that caffeine
isn't hitting your system
so you're just adding to the total
volume of caffeine you're consuming
whilst not contributing to the effect
you want which is the awakeness
much more likely if you get there's a
company called lmnt
who my buddy owns and uh
they do flavored salts so it's
electrolyte salts that
uh athletes would use but they're also
amazing as the first drink of the
morning
and they do a a mango habanero they do a
lemon and chili
they do a chocolate salt raspberry salt
and this with a best part of a pint of
cold water out of the fridge
on a morning with a little squeeze of
lemon juice it takes your head like
lemon have a
mango habanero with a little bit of
lemon takes your head off more than a
coffee
ever will wow and um you just awake man
it's a it's a real
try yeah i'll um give me give me your
address and i'll get joel to send you to
send you a bunch of that stuff down
um man i uh i've been really
enlightened by your love for food i
don't think i know anyone else
i don't have any other friends that love
it as much as you do and i really
i really hope that we've kind of showed
people that it can be something that
they can invest their time into and it
doesn't just need to be the
the annoying bit before that they're not
hungry anymore yeah
no you're banging i mean it's funny
because it's just all like mindset for
me
that's the one thing that is the fun bit
of the day i'm like
two o'clock in the afternoon so i can't
wait to make my dinner i'm looking at
the watch sort of thing it's
um but again it's just what you're into
and hopefully we've given people a
bit of inspiration to get in the kitchen
and just prove it can be easy to make
something delicious
awesome man so at chris baber on
instagram and if people want to hustle
you and also all of the recipes and
stuff we've gone through will be on
there
yeah wicked dude awesome thank you mate
thank you so much
[Music]